ariana grande gets emotional singing
about her late ex-boyfriend Mac Miller
[Applause]
the tearful moment went down at Ariana's
June 12th concert in Mack's hometown
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania the former
couple dated from 2016 to 2018 before
Mack died from an accidental overdose in
September according to fans Ari's
Pittsburgh tour stop had lots of sweet
nods to the late rapper one tweeted that
Ari played a Mack playlist before she
took the stage and get this one said she
even had a seat reserved for him in the
audience it's not the first time this
week that the 25 year old singer
sweetener tour has been in the headlines
[Music]
et has learned the 25 year old popstar
donated a portion of the proceeds from
her June 8th concert in Atlanta to
Planned Parenthood
how much over $300,000 it's important to
note ariana chose to do this
specifically after her Atlanta concert
in May the governor of Georgia passed a
new anti-abortion law which makes it
illegal to have the procedure as soon as
a fetal heartbeat is heard usually the
first six or seven weeks of pregnancy
planned parenthood released a statement
to ET praising Ariana for her commitment
to women's rights quote thanks to
inspiring support like Ariana's Planned
Parenthood can continue to fight back
against these dangerous attacks on
people's health and lives fans of re
know she's been a proud feminist for
years
I love boys but you know I love women
it's equality it's not about being above
men it's about being equal to men she
chooses her projects carefully ones that
have a message like hairspray lies with
everything that's been going on in the
world all the intolerance and ignorance
and hate and ridiculousness it's like
just so crazy how this takes place from
the 60s and like we're still working on
all that and of course songs that just
ooze girl power
Inga's woman done you believe
[Music]